the goat is not even born
because
the generation
that is
present
benefit of a huge advantage
they have knowledge technology that we
didn't have before
and we had the the knowledge that the
other generation did not have before
but
i believe the best the goat is not even
born yet as good as they are today i
think you in sport where you can measure
the performance uh track and field
olympic lifting you can you know someone
is better than the other one because you
can measure the performance fighting
it's all subjective we always debate of
who would win
but 10 the tendency in sport
is that
performance get better i don't think
it's because the athletes necessarily
get better is because they have access
to better technology knowledge
and they learn from their predecessor
as long as that knowledge is transferred
forward
something tells me that the greatest of
all time lived a few thousand years ago
and it's forgotten some of the greatest
warriors like you imagine the kind of
grapplers we just the history didn't
record them
there could have been small tribes where
they developed many ufcs
and they've developed the kind of things
we you have to think of like uh the
gracies just the small family was able
to develop so much so quickly i i often
as this this discussion with johnny i
think it's very important like to
mention i asked you very several time
like what would happen if we would take
a fighter of modern days facing the
champion of pancration this is an
interesting question and you you brought
something incredible good point and and
people don't don't realize it you know
yeah no i think um one of the great
tragedies of martial arts history is our
loss of
uh the historical records of pancration
like most of what we know was uh from
what i'm told is actually lost in the
fires of the library of alexandria and
we're left with only a pitiful amount of
information on pancration matches
but what we do know is that there was a
very
large
participation in the sport and that it
was
widely considered the most popular
sport in the ancient olympics and that
it was represented in the ancient
olympics for many hundreds of years plus
a long period of time before its
introduction into the ancient olympics
and so the development time
that it may have had would have been
very significant it
uh as far as we know most of the
development would have been in the major
greek city states for
uh literally hundreds of years of
development
given its prestige as an olympic sport
then the best athletes would have been
doing it some of the sharpest minds that
we know of
in human history were involved in the
sport
um plato the great philosopher
uh
was a pancreationist in his youth in
fact his name plato is a nickname
platus is like plate
it means broad or big guy like
the big guy and um
uh he spoke often about pain creation
and in his written works
um imagine people with the intelligence
of plato
thinking about
grappling technique for hundreds of
years in the most popular olympic sport
of that time
significant numbers of people with
financial backing as city-states put
great prestige upon olympic success they
would have funneled athletes and
brought in the best coaches and they had
that for many hundreds of years like
it's quite conceivable that the best
pancreatian athletes were of the
absolute first quality
and um uh it it's
it's so sad to think we'll never know
what was their skill level and